>>> WHAT A WEEK.
OUR VILLAIN OF THE DAY,
CONGRESSWOMAN, ALEXANDRIA CASS
YO CORTEZ, PLAYING HER GROWING
ON FAVOR ABILITY ON REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS ON FOX NEWS.
IT IS ALMOST AS IF THERE IS A
DIRECTED FAR RIGHT MACHINE WITH
A WHOLE CABLE NEWS CHANNEL
DEDICATED WITH MALIGNING ME.
>> YOU HAVE ALL THE OTHER
CHANNELS THAT LOVE AND SUPPORT
YOU 24/7, 365.
HAVE YOU STARTED TO NOTICE
RATHER THAN DEFEND THESE
RADICAL, SOCIALIST VIEWS, THE
CONGRESSWOMAN SPENDS MOST OF HER
TIME JUST BLAMING US FOR TALKING
ABOUT THEM AND EXPOSING THEM
ABOUT OIL, GAS, FOSSIL FUEL, AS
A COMBUSTION ENGINE AND GETTING
RID OF PLANES AND COWS, DESTROY
THE ECONOMY.
BEFORE I GO, I HAD PROMOTED
YESTERDAY AND TODAY THAT JUDGE
JEANINE PIRRO WOULD BE JOINING
US TONIGHT ON THE PROGRAM.
SHE HAD A SERIOUS FAMILY
EMERGENCY COME UP, COULDN'T BE
WITH US.
WE ALWAYS PRAY FOR HER.
THAT'S ALL THE TIME WE HAVE
LEFT.
HOPE YOU HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.